[Musik]
Ich bin zum ersten Mal auf Instagram und ich mache diesen Schritt
und erkunde diese neue Art der
Kommunikation für mich,
denn wie wir alle wissen, dass die
Welt in den nächsten Wochen in Schwierigkeiten steckt,
werde ich Nachrichten aufzeichnen
, um zu erklären, was das ist  probleme sind
und wie wir damit umgehen können so
unzureichend schnelle erfüllung
in unseren stars we call on lily reinhardt
designerin und victoria beckham
model stephanie gizinga prinz william
und herzegowin kate
die amerikanerin
aus dem guinness-
weltrekord abschluss suzanne new inventory court
dritter tag welche aussage ungeschlagen an
nervige beste seite auf der einerman
follower mark zuckerberg
dich